spuren eines brutalen mordes mitten in
der dresdner altstadt
es ist der vierte oktober 2020 thomas l
und sein lebenspartner sind auf dem weg
zurück zum hotel um 21 uhr 25 sticht der
attentäter plötzlich mit zwei messern
auf sie ein
thomas l stirbt im krankenhaus der wirt
55 jahre alt in seiner heimatstadt
krefeld trauern freunde weggefährten und
die schwul lesbische community
[Musik]
ich kannte ihn persönlich wir waren auch
sag mal in den anfangsjahren schon ein
bisschen befreundet eher introvertiert
nur ruhiger feinfühliger mensch ziemlich
erschrocken dass das hat jemand
erstochen ist und nur noch um sexuell
ist das habe ich schon sehr betroffen
gemacht dass man sich menschen aus sucht
die vorher noch eine zärtliche geste
machbar erkennbar war dass es sich dabei
um ein schwules pärchen handelt und dass
man dann halt auch so menschen ein stich
und dann hier hier in deutschland ist
fand schon sehr überraschend und auch
erschüttern
zwei wochen nach dem anschlag nimmt die
polizei den mutmaßlichen täter fest der
ist den behörden seit langem bekannt
abdullah kommt 2015 als flüchtlinge aus
syrien nach sachsen 2018 verurteilt ihn
das oberlandesgericht dresden zu einer
haftstrafe
der damals 18-jährige war anhänger des
und hatte einen selbstmordanschlag
geplant
im gefängnis hat abdullah kontakt zu
sozialpädagogen die auf die
radikalisierung spezialisiert sind
das team von thomas mücke hat ihn
betreut
wir hatten den eindruck von
gehabt dass es ein mensch ist der nicht
ein sichtbar ist was in ihnen vorgeht
der voller frustration auch hass
gewissen war der auch eine reihe von
vorteilen hatten gegenüber andere
lebensweisen anderen menschen das
belegen auch chats von abdullah h
die die behörden auf seinem handy fanden
er fragte einen anderen islamisten darf
man deutsche töten
ja es ist erlaubt weil sie ungläubige
sind und gott und seinen propheten
bekämpfen
später wird abdullah gefragt wir hören
dass ihr menschen mit dem messer
schlachtet warum wir schlachten
ausschließlich diejenigen die vom
glauben abfallen
dazu zählen für islamisten auch schwule
hamid kennt dieses feindbild sehr genau
heute arbeitet er im team von thomas
mücke will nicht erkannt werden früher
war er selbst ein radikaler islamist
wenn ich leute gesehen oder männer
gesehen habe jetzt schwule da habe ich
ein hass gespürt gegen die man wusste
und das sind die schlimmsten sünder weil
gott hat sozusagen mann und frau
erschafft und wenn man genau das
gegenteil macht dann ist mein feind
gottes wenn jetzt ein terrorist die wahl
hätte normale menschen oder schwule
er wurde sofort die schwulen angreifen
und zuerst töten wollen
die tat von dresden konnten thomas mücke
und seine mitarbeiter nicht verhindern
eines der wichtigsten ziele die wir
haben es zukünftige opfer zu vermeiden
so und das ist dann nicht der fall
sondern menschen wurde das leben einfach
auf diese barbarische art und weise
genommen und das schmerzhafte an diesem
fall war gewesen dass wir nichts
gefunden haben wo wir sagen können da
hätte man was anderes machen können
nur fünf tage nach seiner haftentlassung
soll abdullah h den anschlag begangen
haben
der generalbundesanwalt hat anklage
wegen mordes erhoben und benennt
schwulenfeindlichkeit als ein tatmotiv
der grüne landtagsabgeordnete valentin
lippmann verlangt aufklärung warum
konnte abdul ahad töten obwohl er als
islamistische gefährder von den
sächsischen behörden observiert wurde
fakt ist dass man offensichtlich nicht
davon ausgehen dass er unmittelbar eine
entsprechende straftat durchführen würde
anders kann ich mir nicht erklären warum
man in diesem fall die observation in
den ersten tagen nach der haftentlassung
nur sehr lückenhaft durchgeführt hat
[Musik]
gedenken an thomas l vergangenen
november in krefeld die schwul lesbische
community mahnt das homophobe tatmotiv
nicht zu verschweigen
wir leben in offenen gesellschaften
einer toleranten gesetzt und da muss man
muss man solche solche sachen klar
benennen dürfen sagen dass das ein
islamist war das ist dass man muss sagen
dass das eine radikale strömung waren
deshalb homophob das muss man sagen
dürfen und das muss unsere gesellschaft
beitragen können gewalt gegen
homosexuelle in deutschland gibt es dazu
kaum zahlen nur in berlin
dort sind homophobe gewalttaten von 2018
auf 2019 um 26 prozent gestiegen
die polizistin anna von knoblauch ist
ansprechpartnerin für schwule und lesben
in berlin
die täter seien meist junge männer die
aus der gruppe heraus angreifen die
gewaltbereitschaft steigt es gibt
massive übergriffe in ungarn dort gibt
es tritte gegen den kehlkopf wo wirklich
ganz schlimme verletzungen die folge
sind ja oder auch lebensbedrohliche
situation entstehen können die
religionszugehörigkeit der täter wird
nicht erfasst aber vor allem
berlin-neukölln fällt durch einen hohen
anteil gefährlicher körperverletzungen
auf viele schwule und lesben berichten
dass sie sich hier nicht trauen hand in
hand zu gehen weil in neukölln viele
arabisch und türkisch stämmige
jugendliche mit homophoben einstellungen
lebten
ich kann das insoweit nachvollziehen
dass ich den dass ich dieses gefühl auch
selbst kenne also es gibt große quere
clubs in berlin die sich beispielsweise
in nord-neukölln befinden und wenn man
da frühmorgens nach einem besuch nach
hause geht dann guckt man schon manchmal
lieber dreimal ich würde das aber nicht
auf diese communitys allein begrenzten
doch während homophobe taten von
neonazis klar verurteilt würden tue sich
auch seine partei bei islamistischen
attentätern deutlich schwerer
ich erlebe häufig in der
gesellschaftlichen linken dass es dazu
zwar eine klare haltung gibt die aber
höchstens verschämt geäußert wird weil
man sorge hat rechtsradikalen kräften
argumentation futter zu liefern nämlich
dass der islam nicht vereinbar sei
mit unserem
gesellschaftsmodell dabei wäre hier
eigentlich selbstbewusstsein angebracht
weil sie in frankreich auch im
vergangenen oktober der lehrer samuel
partie ermordet wurde stand präsident
marko ramm sack und verurteilte die tat
als islamistischen terror angriff und in
deutschland dort überlässt es die
kanzlerin ihrem sprecher die tat von
dresden zu verurteilen
im namen der bundeskanzlerin der
bundesregierung möchte ich sagen wir
trauern um den ermordeten und unsere
gesamte aufrichtige anteilnahme gilt
seiner familie und seinen freunden
während wir in frankreich sehen dass
sogar in manacor persönlich anteilnahme
bekundet und den dort ermordeten
geschichtslehrer partie sogar als
gesicht frankreichs erdähnliche
anteilnahme wäre auch in deutschland
notwendig und dann sollte die
bundesregierung endlich auch den kampf
gegen homo- und transphobie zu einer
priorität der innenpolitik machen
solange das nicht geschieht müssen
schwule und lesben fürchten zur
zielscheibe zu werden wenn sie sich
offen mit ihren partnern zeigen
[Musik]